Axel and Santiago I'd love to talk about
recreating the trial scenes and you were
able to shoot in the Palace of Justice
where the trial took place that must
have felt surreal how did you secure
that location Axel well I mean the theme
I mean both uh you know the art director
Michaela and the location manager and
everybody was very imaginatively it's
the movie it's basically an act of love
as you can see and nobody had ever made
a movie about this this is the first
time ever not even a had anyone ever
tried to make this movie before we don't
know I mean it's amazing I mean if
somebody's right it didn't happen you
know so I we were quite surprised uh
when when uh finally they allowed us to
to sit there but for Santiago as you say
this thousand times before but it
changed a lot shooting the the trial on
on the real place where it happened
it for me it was uh super important uh
to to shoot in the in the real courtroom
I I knew it was going to be difficult
but luckily the producers did a magnific
job on convincing the right people to to
let us shoot we we didn't suspend any
trial or anything which during the
holidays uh and on the um
uh in odd hours in odd hours so yeah and
but for me it was super important uh
because uh
well the the the the parts of the trial
on the public hearings start and we
start to listen to the to the
witnesses
it's uh it's well it's the heart of the
film The the warmed the the the the the
worm the the harm the heart of the film
so uh I I I I I knew I wanted to lose a
little bit of the fiction at that part
so we there was one thing that was
interesting that the the original taping
of the of the trial the broadcasting of
Israel was done from from the back from
the uh from the next of the of the
witnesses because it was dangerous for
them it was in order to protect the
witnesses yeah so so I understood that I
need to show now that we have the time
has passed I could shoot uh I needed to
shoot the faces and try to imagine what
those persons may have feel uh for about
talking for the first time about what
they lived in um
concentration comes
um and but but I want you to lose
fiction so that the the words are
exactly the same words than than the the
people who gave testimony indeed and and
I also it was important to use uh the
original footage of the trial I was
going to ask about that did you
interweave footage with your own footage
yeah well it's something we designed
with the dop with
that he had a very clever idea uh we we
were using like a humanic camera uh to
make um that it was the same camera that
it was used in the 85 uh to make it like
a fake footage with our actors and then
we could introduce that footage in the
viewfinders of the camera that was the
prop and then through that viewfinder we
could get into the actual archive and
and go back without the well hiding this
uh this idea or well making less uh
notorious noticeable noticeable
noticeable it's a difficult foreign
Spanish speaking person
but yeah it was important and also it
was important for me in the
in the ending of the final indictment
but I will we will talk about that if I
assume so I can say it afterwards no of
course no I'm feel free yeah yeah no I'm
not because no I will I will say it
afterwards
and what was the most difficult aspect
of recreating 1985 because I've read
that you said it would be just as
difficult as to do 1925. that there
really wouldn't be that much difference
in trying to recreate this time which is
now almost 40 years ago I think I
exaggerated a little bit but that's okay
it's more fun because it's there's a lot
more cars from the 80s than probably
from the 20s to find but there's not
many cars in good shape from the 80s in
Buenos Aires so we needed to I don't
know to look everywhere and and to add a
lot of CGI well not a lot but some CGI
in the in the city and and duplicating
The Cars one all that stuff that we do
but it was it was a lot more difficult
than what I expected but um with
Michaela who is the production designer
and with Monica who is the costume
designer we wanted like uh make a subtle
reconstruction of the 80s we understood
that the film the topic of the film was
so important that we needed nothing to
be over the top I appreciated that there
wasn't any distracting music and
clothing the 80s was a little kind of
weird style at times yeah yeah yeah so
so yeah you wouldn't when yeah okay
they're a little bit quiche in the 80s
but it's really easy to go over the top
and have you know bad shoulders and
stuff like that it's like I mean I know
it was like that here I assume you were
more stylish in the 80s than we were
well I don't think so but yeah we try to
find some some some key elements like
the walkmans and the cassettes and the
radios the old telephones the whole time
people smoking yes I noticed a lot of
smoking yeah
but I think that those elements were
already uh enough time traveling uh so
that we needed to we did we didn't need
to point uh everything all the time
let's say no there was a lot of
restraint which I appreciated and
Ricardo obviously you never had a chance
to meet with stressera and talk to him
about this they went to the same school
but did you know him did you know
straight Sarah
if you had the chance to speak to him
what is one question you would ask
I'm really curious about that answer
it's a good one
I don't know really I am
um
foreign
so
soon
ER
[Music]
is
he
is
um
he would be a lot to ask it would be
really hard for me to find one question
to ask him I know about his uh humility
I know about his honesty I know about
his um truthfulness but to find one
single question it would be a lot to ask
understood
and in closing you know America is
dealing with its own problems in terms
of the fragility of our democracy and a
lot of us are very afraid extremely
afraid and we saw this play out on
television this week as recently as this
week
which still processing that
what do you hope each of us takes away
from this film no matter where we live I
mean each of us has a responsibility in
the same way that stressera employed his
own power and passion what do you want
each of us to take away from this film
pelicula
uh
Nueva
recorded
moral
solidaridad
pelicula
muy Feliz
there's nothing we can really do about
the past we can focus on the present and
of course my goal is to think about the
future and if I have to think about
something that I would really like
um to transmit with this film is to
really touch the hearts of the younger
generations and the young blood and show
them and teach them that
um they can still believe in in honesty
Integrity
um truthfulness
courageousness and all of those values
that are so important and that would be
my goal is to touch the hearts and the
minds of all the younger Generations
thank you yes agreed
an excellent Santiago any closing
thoughts or or hopes for for the
audience American audiences but again
the global audience well
um
one of the reasons I I
worked on this film
from the beginning was I have to vote
there on a son there over there my son
is 14 years old my daughter is 10.
and when we were working on this I was
thinking about exactly what Ricardo said
about the future but also
I think we have to be really uh aware of
the dangers that democracy is facing
everywhere not only in America
everywhere we have to be really we have
to have strong takes on accountability
nobody should be about the law anywhere
not even in this country
and that's my take
yes thank you thank you
I think my partners say said already
enough so thank you thank you all for
being here and really thank you for
making thank you very much thank you for
telling this story thank you very much
thank you for coming have a great night
appreciate it